the next 18 messages on my phone where
dudes really trying hard to me
which by call seven was getting
flattering
[Music]
he's my good friend you know from the
past Legion escapes
[Music]
my story is a tough one baring my soul
little bit here I'm not going to be the
hero of this story it's about cheating
it's about me cheating and I know
generally I think of myself as a pretty
likable comedian but once I start
talking about me cheating I realize how
white trash I look like it's very I'm
wearing knuckle gloves for fashion I
have wallet chains I wear a scarf in my
back pocket that a friend told me
recently I thought was an extra t-shirt
I keep because I'm fat definitely
sending the wrong message but this
happened about 13 years ago I got caught
cheating I was with my daughter's mother
at the time and I was a 23 year old fat
kid doing comedy and after a show one
night I met a girl very pretty I was
very insecure it was so nice to have
this really cute chick wall up to me and
she made an offer I kind of couldn't
refuse it was essentially one of
you know I was like yeah I would like to
and we did and you know you're supposed
to do with the girl who walks up and
says wanna
after you you make her your
long-term sod girlfriend
which I went ahead and did and I was
seeing it for when it was a wild a wild
time a lot of things out of my
wheelhouse she was younger than me and I
was taking naked pictures of her she was
taking naked pictures of me were
in all kinds of weird places it was good
time but I'm doing a bad bad thing and
one day I'm at the side girl's house and
as I'm looking through my phone for
something she notices that her phone
number is under a fake name and she goes
what's that all about and I was like oh
now here's the mistake I'm making in
cheating and I'm not encouraging this or
telling you how to do it but if you do
you can't lie to both chicks one of them
has to know what's going on if I really
I really enjoyed there's a girl nodding
her head like I'm giving a speech about
the pipeline or some she's like
give those natives back their land one
of them's got to know the truth I was
lying to both that's a mistake so when
she goes why is my number different in
your phone and my name's not on your
phone I was like oh yeah you know when
we first met I didn't remember your name
so I put it in as a different name I
knew it started with an L and she's like
yeah but it says Larry
that it does she's like you're lying to
me something's weird you're lying I go I
know you're crazy you're being crazy
let me show you how not afraid I am to
have your name on my phone I put her
name her number now as her first name my
last name and then I go home yeah I go
home that night and like a real true
piece of I put my cell phone every
night in my pillowcase I told you I
don't look I promise I get mine at the
end of this I usually turn it off put it
in my pillowcase why would I tell my ex
that because I don't like to be bothered
when I'm asleep so I keep my phone often
in my pillowcase was a terrible lie but
I didn't turn it off that night in the
morning this girl the side girl starts
calling my phone a ton and I'm sleeping
like a baby cherub I'm so peaceful she
eventually my ex picks up the phone and
sees this girl's first name with my last
name and is like you know I've never
heard of this cousin or auntie she goes
ahead and answers the phone who's this
J's girlfriend who's this J's girlfriend
and then the nightmare happens they have
an hour-long conversation about me well
I am sleeping like no one's be I'm just
scratching balls
visions of sugarplums they talk for an
hour they figure it all out my ex was in
law school at the time that's important
in the story because she woke me up by
pegging me in the face with a law book
very thick book a lot of torts and I
must have been civil law or something it
was a lot and she wakes me up we have a
terrible terrible argument and
everything blows up in my face and now
two people in the world absolutely
hate me and I deserve that I get
that but the saving grace in my life at
the time was I feel terrible I'm a human
being
I know I've hurt people but I'm like you
know what I just remembered that they
after tomorrow I'm going to South Africa
for three weeks it's gonna be I get to
get away from all this for a little bit
let the heat die down and then that
night I got a reminder on my phone that
says I'm not leaving for South Africa
for an entire other week so I gotta live
in this hatred for a week and every day
is just two people finding me and
cursing me out and kicking me in the
nuts I got the whole deal and the nights
were bad I was drinking a lot I have
some weird stories from my I was driven
home one night by a midget I don't know
if I knew him before that night I don't
think I did I just remember the whole
Drive going like as he get those pedals
but cuz he's big wood sticks to come up
it's freaky the night before I left for
South Africa I drunkenly got these two
star tattoos on my elbows right before I
sat in the middle seat of a twenty six
hour flight to South Africa
it sucked I'm in South Africa I'm very
sad things are not going good for me in
my life I'm bummed out I'm there for
about a week and I'm like you know what
this is before the time of us
International cellphone plans this is
calling card so I go let me check
my messages on my cell phone and I dial
up the numbers and I go it says you have
19 messages the first message is my
friend Wayne a gay man who lives in the
East Village of New York City very gay
he goes hey pal I was just cruising
through Craigslist men looking for men
[Applause]
and I saw I saw an ad with your name in
it a naked picture of you and it is you
with your phone number and your TV
credits he goes I don't know if there's
something that you wanted but I feel
like it's not so I'm gonna go ahead and
flag it for you okay
Wayne's gonna take care of that all
right Wayne's on the job and the picture
by the way for the record
meaning this girl she got out of the
shower one day the side girl in a towel
and she flashed open I took a picture of
her and she was like no fair I know what
do you wanna take a picture of me and
she goes yeah so jokingly is I'm out of
the shower too and I mean with real just
took a shower dick
it's a picture of me full-body
butt-naked 70 pounds heavier with my
arms up in the door jamb really trying
to stretch it all out just trying to get
the best if there was a centerfold of
fat quarterly that's what it would be
that's the fat Tom Selleck yeah well no
it's right whoever said that is right it
wasn't a flattering picture however the
next 18 messages on my phone we're dudes
really trying hard to me
which by call 7 was getting flattering
some of those dudes wanted to me
bad I mean they put it
Steve got named Steve called like five
times and he called me bare which was
adorable it was like hey bear why don't
you call me back there
I saw that you were recently on vh1's
why are you wearing this forty celebrity
slim downs and I was uh I was pretty
panicky about it but it was flagged and
I was like alright no harm no foul and
through all this me and my daughter's
mother stayed together we had a long
talk and we uh we got through it we're
not together now but at this one we got
through and I thought all was well and
then I found out how you get something
flagged on Craigslist is a lot of people
have to do it and I was like wait how
did you just flag it he goes nah don't
worry we got a flag it's no big deal
I go okay all right well it's gone
that's all that matters you can't find
it and then uh do you guys remember a
comedy mentor of mine I'm sure a lot of
you guys know the late great Patrice
O'Neal he was like a big brother to me
and really embraced me when I went to
New York and and for as long as I lived
in New York while he was alive every
Thanksgiving me my daughter my ex would
go to his house for Thanksgiving and my
daughter's a baby still and that next
Thanksgiving I go to Patricia's house
and he goes uh he goes hey man Happy
Thanksgiving
hey J do me a favor could you go uh hit
the mouse on the computer real quick
I was like why what's up man
music just uh just go ahead smack them
reluctantly I walk over and smack this
thing his whole screensaver is just a
big old picture I'm pretty sure he died
with that on his computer I hope
that house burns down here that uh
Patrice's mom has a picture of my dick
somewhere in her house I want to say
something before I get out of here you
guys are awesome I'll tell you
that's this show is very important to me
man it really is because with all some
of the cool things have happened me four
happen for me over the last couple of
years Comedy Central special and and
being on the radio and all this cool
stuff started because Ari Shaffir the
when this was still a digital show they
were only using La comments and he
wanted me on this show so bad he
personally flew me out from New York and
put me up in his apartment to get me on
the show which led to so many other
things and this is my fourth or
fifth story I've told on the show and
that means the world to me that they
keep bringing me back so keep supporting
the show man thank you